[Musique]
à chaque grand carrefour de la capitale
des vents de en proposent aux passants
qui se les arrachent
dans des paliers à même le sol ou encore
dans ses casseroles encore chaud des
insectes
qui s'ils n'ont rien de repoussant au
contraire
c'est un peu le goût de la viande ou
bien du poulet
c'est vraiment délicieux
ces petites friandises ce sont des
sauterelles
la plupart viennent d'ici le district de
massaka dans le centre de l'ouganda
[Musique]
ces jeunes hommes sont des chasseurs de
sauterelles comme tous les jours il
installe cette curieuse structure au
coucher du soleil
quelques barils alignés et au dessus des
plaques de tôle ondulée un piège
savamment mises en place
allez on le prépare correctement comme
ça ce soir on va attraper plein de ce
trail
ok
on doit l'installer chaque jour chaque
jour et on doit le défaire tous les
matins c'est comme ça qu'on récupère ce
qu'il contient
lorsque la nuit tombe tout est prêt il
ne reste qu'à allumer le dispositif
les ampoules suralimenté crachent leurs
lumières aveuglantes qui se reflète sur
la tôle
un îlot plus hauts récents apparaît
c'est donc un piège lumineux il attire
toutes les sauterelles à la ronde
à zilina ce cas qui passe dans le ciel
sont tombés contre ces plaques de tôle
et glisse dans ce bar il
alors on attend jusqu'au petit matin
pourront récupérer un maximum sera-t-il
cannes collecte d'un halo forme encore
gwokas les chasseurs mouiller les barils
pour empêcher les poids de remonter eux
mêmes sont brûlés par les lumières
surpuissante
à cause des lampes ma peau est
totalement sèche et le matin je peine
et mes yeux aussi me formalise sont
complètement sec lui aussi regarde sa
peau elle peut elle et ça ça lui brûle
les yeux
pour renforcer encore le faisceau
lumineux il embrasse des herbes humide
la fumée blanche concentrent la lumière
un savoir faire hérité d'une longue
tradition
dans la nuit d'autres pièges s'illumine
à perte de vue c'est toute une région
qui vit au rythme de cette chasse aux
sauterelles
et juste avant l'aube
c'est lors de la collecte
[Musique]
on en n'a pas attrapé beaucoup ce soir
une douzaine de sacs tout de même de
plusieurs dizaines de kilos chacun ils
sont chargés sur la voiture il faut
maintenant faire vite
les insectes doivent arriver vivant et
le plus tôt possible son le grand marché
de la capitale kampala
[Musique]
aux premières lueurs du jour
les acheteurs évalue la marchandise
et les négociations commencent
il n'y a pas de prix fixe un jour c'est
à ce niveau là le lendemain beaucoup
plus bas ça change constamment
en moins d'une ribes brahim katongo l'a
déjà tout vendu et empocher près de 750
euros et les vendeurs continuent à
arriver de tout le pays
dans une immense couilles
moins cher mais s'entraîne moins cher
il faut ensuite les préparer des
centaines de petites mains s'affairent
les ailes les pattes et là que sont
arrachés comme pour des crevettes
elles sont revendus comme ça décortiqué
prête à être cuisinés à la maison
je les vends un peu moins de deux euros
par tasse comme celle ci
ce soir lorsque je vais rentrer ma femme
va les faire frire ça sera parfait ça va
être mon petit casse croûte ça va être
délicieux
la teneur en protéines des sauterelles
est bien supérieure à celle du boeuf ou
du poisson c'est aussi un aliment sain
bon marché et écologique selon tous les
experts
une série de qualité qui en prend un
coup sur un ingrédient incontournable de
l'alimentation de demain